uh Jim Jordan then last night went on
Tim Poole's podcast which they shot from
Lauren bobert's office a lot of names
here uh and they mentioned a little
something about me and Elon and what
else has been going on over there there
are these apps you can use where you
enter your name and it'll tell you the
various filters that exist but even Dave
Rubin just mentioned Elon Musk just
showed him new ones they discovered new
filters but but I guess you know what
I'm thinking is
we often focus on the censorship aspect
which I think culturally and morally
those of us who care about real debate
and and logic and policy are shocked by
but I'm also curious how can Twitter as
a massive Corp company with 300 million
plus users lie about the product they're
delivering how can a corporation in
America say I'm gonna imagine this
imagine if a company said you come to me
here's a contract you get a gallon of
whole milk then they give you a gallon
of two percent yeah that sounds like
they're they're they're falsely
advertising what they're delivering if
Twitter says the reverse chronological
feed delivers you reverse chronological
posts but then they're using Shadow ban
algorithms and we know they are they're
lying to their customers as to the
product being delivered how is that
legal how is it allowed yeah so what
other questions asked too that you made
me think of this too I asked this
question
um and I I didn't fully understand but
but I asked if they were hard coding
into any specific account to censor them
so they're like targeting that specific
user uh and it was interesting how Joel
Roth kind of I want to go back and look
at the transcript to see exactly how he
said it because he really didn't so that
square
um that either I agree one of the things
we want to do with with legislation that
we're we're planning on doing with
Energy and Commerce Committee
is anything they do to your account they
have to tell you there has to be real
transparency there has to be a time
frame there has to be a due process so
that you can correct it figure out what
it is to have the debate and correct
within a specified amount of time and
then if they don't then you should have
some kind of cause of action because
they're violating a contract that they
have with you their user their customer
okay so I like the end of that right
he's talking about the the user
agreement we all sign that means you
have responsibilities they have
responsibilities you know sort of like
when you buy a product and that product
blows up in your face they might be held
accountable for that I do and we will
reach out to Jim Jordan's team
immediately after the show we put this
thing together on the Fly today when
he's talking about is it hardwired to to
people's specific accounts I know that
the answer is yes because when we did
the Deep dive into my account they found
things that were just on my account and
then they they've also found that they
were on other people's accounts as well
but meaning they were going it was
account specific we don't like Dave
Rubin we're going to attach this stuff
related to misinformation and be like it
was literally like being mean and like a
couple other things so we know that it
is hardwired in there and that's why
it's so difficult to uh to take out and
uh I will we'll get that to Jim George
Jim are you watching well this is for
you dude
[Music]
thank you